- [Narrator] It's Election Day.
While it's unclear which races
Republicans and Democrats will win...
- It could be days, perhaps even longer
before we know the final midterm results.
- [Narrator] What is certain is that
this election looks different
for voters across the US.
- There are many laws in many states
that voters are gonna
be having to navigate
for the first time this year.
- [Narrator] In the wake of
the contentious 2020 election,
(people screaming)
rules have changed and more
observers have been deployed.
Here's a look at how the
presidential election
made a lasting impact and
why some people are concerned
that the changes we see this
year from voting regulations
and voting methods to poll watchers,
could affect voter turnout and
the future of our elections.
At least 40 states have passed
laws in the last two years
that either tighten voting
rules or expand voting access
according to NYU's Brennan
Center For Justice,
a public policy think-tank that
tracks election legislation.
- If we're talking about
whether it's become harder
or easier to vote, and I
really think it depends
on where a voter happens to live.
- [Narrator] Since 2020, 28
states have passed measures
that would make it easier
for eligible Americans
to register, stay, on the rolls, or vote.
In Vermont, all registered voters
will be mailed a ballot for
the November presidential
and midterm elections
under a law passed in 2021.
And in Kentucky, a new
law established three days
of early in-person voting.
- [Jasleen] Expansive
voting laws are recognition
by legislators that more access
means a more full, fair,
and engaged democracy.
- [Narrator] 20 states have passed laws
that the Brennan Center
classifies as restrictive,
which can include measures
that shorten windows
to apply for a mail ballot,
limit the availability
of ballot dropboxes,
impose stricter signature requirements
or impose stricter voter ID requirements.
Among these are Arizona's HB2492 law,
which established a proof
of citizenship requirement
for voter registration,
and Georgia's SB202, which requires voters
to provide an approved type of ID,
like a driver's license or
voter identification card
when requesting and
returning an absentee ballot.
Republicans say the changes
were needed to restore
confidence among voters in
the integrity of elections,
while Democrats believe
the law is meant to depress
minority turnout, and that
former President Donald Trump
and his supporters corroded
faith in the process.
- [Group] Give our taxes!
- [Narrator] No evidence of
widespread fraud has been found
in the 2020 election, but
the unsubstantiated claims
have motivated some
people to get involved.
While poll watching is a common feature,
where people monitor
ballot casting and counting
for possible rule violations,
there are concerns that
highly partisan volunteers
could try to intimidate voters this year.
- One of the features
of our election system
is this transparency,
the ability of people
to watch and observe,
but it also does create a vulnerability
if a bad actor gets in.
- [Narrator] Trey Grayson oversaw
two presidential electionS
and two midterm elections
as Kentucky Secretary of State.
- We have to make sure
that the observers aren't
intimidating voters
or doing something that
they shouldn't be doing
during that observation process.
- [Narrator] The RNC says it has recruited
over 123,000 poll
workers and poll watchers
in primary, general, and
special elections this cycle.
The DNC said state level
democratic parties take the lead
on recruiting poll watchers.
- It all comes back to
balancing the transparency
of our system with not wanting
folks to be intimidated.
We don't want voters to feel
like somebody's watching or
will do something to them
and that causes them to not vote.
- More than 43 million
ballots have been cast
as of November 7th, and there are signs
that this year's elections could meet
or possibly exceed 2018's midterm turnout.
It'll take until well after the election
when most or all mail-in
ballots have been counted
before we get a full picture
of voter participation.
- We'll find out if that's
just a sign of people shifting
their voting preference
or a sign of high overall turnout.
- A recent Wall Street Journal poll
shows voter enthusiasm is
high with 81% of respondents
saying they definitely
will vote this year,
and 8% saying they already have.
- I'm gonna be looking
for some of these new laws
that we're seeing in
states, how they work,
how they impact turnout
and also the the poll watcher issue.
And then finally, I wanna see the results
of some of these election
administrative races,
secretary of states and a few governors
that appoint secretaries
'cause that could have a tremendous impact
on the future of our elections.
(gentle music)